it's one of those things that you can't
hide wherever you go you are the doctor
well it's okay because these guys didn't
know what it was yeah you could hide
backstage yeah it's an interesting it's
an interesting thing particularly a
Briton but weirdly the show you can't
predict a demographic it's it's all over
the world
and so the reason that thing where you
go okay so you know I'm walking around
this place I don't need my hat and then
the oddest kind of moment will happen
and you go on
maybe they recognize Moe but if you're
me you have a slight narcissism what you
think everyone's recognizing you that's
such an embarrassing thing I have this
read yesterday all the Jew so is it I've
always to got like Oh anyway right
basically what happened so I stood on
Oxford Tube platform yeah
and I've always got em so you know like
a glass keep coupe you know like it
rather than going to a coffee shop and
get in a new cup
I carry a glass one that are then wash
and reget malate and so I got I got my
empty cup and I was just stood at down
stuff and an elderly gentleman was
walking towards me on the platform I was
just so I just just wanna get on the
tube recognized then he had his arm out
and his am came into my space and on the
tube on the platform it's crowded and
it's a bit I don't know I just got the
candle I I were doing a bit aggressive
unnecessarily and actually what he was
doing was he when I saw I thought you
wanted money
[Applause]
I was like some make eye contacts I can
tell this story you can't hide you can't
put ask I mean but yeah I I mean I've
seen you in a gym like at a public gym
so do you get you get bothered all the
time all the time yeah how do you gone
out the window how do you work out in
the gym of people to constantly give me
help to you
just be nice say hello get a-movin but
fame is a funny thing right so you have
that story for you well that will be
like the constant anchoring reminder
right like how cool Fame is but also
never like I don't have the stress you
have though because I think the thing is
if you if you are 5 or 6 and you've got
hat on and you dressed like a most the
time a teenage boy in a baseball cap
headphones on head down I catch the bus
and the I catch the bus on the subway
every single day because I'm not in
anyone's eye line like that but I
imagine you there is something about if
if you're you you can't
Kevin's had weird you've had weird fan
okay well what happens if you're three
foot two like
how do you deal with that
- I'm sorry nerd I mean when it comes to
Harry Potter I'm a massive massive nerd
we know that because you posted this
because this year 12 or 13 12 or 13 here
this is Margot Robbie
look how long cool hardback Harry Potter
do you know what's particularly pathetic
about this picture a couple things
really let you point them out number one
it's my birthday that's how I chose to
spend my birthday what was in the car
number two I'm drinking tea number three
I'm wearing glasses even though I don't
need glasses I lied to the optometrist
because I wanted to have glasses what
you were were you gonna Harry Potter
finally no I love Harry Potter I just to
get round to read in the last one okay
so not just ours but I started doing
them do it layin and are you kidding me
so you've read one two six and you
haven't read the seven yeah I don't know
are you actually kidding baby bear for
twins I'm not gonna be able to sleep
tonight what worrying about life is a
game you mean it's just you keep it on
the edge I mean this is insane to me
do you know another fun fact my husband
is your thing this is
[Applause]
so sorry I brought this up I'll stop
hijacking the job let go because I'm not
here my husband is in the Harry Potter
movies I know I was like had you told me
sooner we would have married very
quickly but he was an extra he was
saying when he was a little kid he's
like one of his slow that are not extras
you know when Draco like pushes some
kids out of the way to to see Buckbeak
in the third book yeah he pushes my
husband out you've noticed something
about British people and the way they
speak that we do a funny thing
no I mean I love all the every regional
you're not gonna give you that scar mess
but I like that because there's so many
accents to such a small country
everybody sort of puts on different
voices when they're doing a little bit
so yeah yeah but I had a thing where I
was checking into a hotel and somebody
came out and said oh dude you'd help
with your bags and I've I thought they
were doing a bit
kept talking like that I had to like
slowly transition out of it know that
that sounds like an exaggeration of
their voice but then I was back in the
country several years later and they
were on TV on goggle box cuz it was deaf
and Dom from God
so they actually talked like that I
never knew that that was a real hotel
yeah you say there right there yes has
written a book yes look under your seats
I already on top before we talk about it
I'm going to say because it's true it is
a really funny book I say that because
it may not be initially in parent when
you start talking about what it's about
yes pre-empting my poor salesmanship
because I tend to put people off
anything that's to do with me well
you're very kind to say that it is very
funny but now you need to tell people
what it's about
okay and let me do some damage now so it
is about a Gwyneth Paltrow films called
view from the top
I mean which she plays the stupidest
this is the post room you seen this film
is it's a real film I saw yeah yeah yes
it's a real film well baccala do I need
to see it literally you do not need to
if you've seen any film you have seen
this film it is very similar to all film
plays a blue-collar worker I don't know
what research she did maybe into Whole
Foods one and she dreams of becoming an
air stewardess she becomes one that's
the film dilemma can she be an air
stewardess and maintain a loving
relationship with Mark Ruffalo oh yeah
no being an ask us a to ownerís
she's got to hand out salty nuts
this'll blow ething she's got to
demonstrate it's a nightmare
what should she do you're literally the
opposite of on the edge of your seats
stop telling me the story
she manages to reconcile with Mark
Ruffalo there's quite the salty notes
[Applause]
the end is a huge gun battle ends down
and kisses him but this is essentially a
sort of academic reading of it as if
it's a classic I yes I saw this film
with my wife that's not a joke it's
possible that someone would choose that
and I was so haunted by this film but
it's taken me three years to exercise my
system and I've gone through the book in
forensic detail explaining why it's so
important and I've been to open it with
things from my life it really is so
important to give this film the respect
it deserves
people haven't seen it people aren't
discussing it can you believe this is
the first book about this film
the tricep people aren't taking it
seriously does Gwyneth know about this
yeah she's not emailed me as yet no she
may be you know in the middle of the
cleanse
[Applause]
now Sir Patrick Stewart and you don't
really use the surra much do you sorry
so I've been calling you know I
shouldn't am I supposed to know okay but
no do you I take my lead from Sir Ian I
whom we've both shared some time with
yes and he is he is so phlegmatic about
all of that and and I just you know it's
a great honour but it's not something
that I need to press when you bump into
another sir when you're out and about do
you then do you roll in sir circles
circles so how do you become sir
well Patrick how well you know it's a
case of
I got mine on the Queen's Birthday
Honours but you have reminded me that I
did have a sir encounter only a few
weeks ago in Los Angeles rather fancy in
fact extremely fancy restaurant tell
what it is they'll know it was the the
tower bar I know
[Applause]
you keep going I got a feeling this
isn't gonna work out so we're the four
of us were seated at a table about 15
minutes later into the restaurant walks
Sir Paul McCartney Wow
good now uh Paul and I have a very
slender relationship but it's lasted
decades encountered him in 1964 no when
his girlfriend Jane Asher then had told
him that I loved Aston Martin's I was
driving a battered old Ford but Aston
Martin's were my dream car she told him
this and one night yeah we knew he was
seeing the show there was a knock on my
door and I said yeah come in I'm there
in my underwear yeah like that's useful
[Laughter]
I'm ready for you
and the door opened standing there was
Paul McCartney who I had never met
before and this was 1964 he said Jane
says that you like Aston Martin's here
drive this Wow and he tossed a bunch of
keys also pretty cool and it was ass
[Applause]
we're now in the tower bar
I am feeling less he sees me and comes
over and I stand up and say hi and we
have a big hug in the restaurant and I'm
very much aware that there's all the
tables are full on this kind of thing
and we talked for five or six minutes
and he goes and sits down five minutes
go by and into the restaurant walks sir
Ringo Starr I swear to you they were
they were oh they were at the same table
they were the same yes well we're at the
tower free meal
we finish early and I get up to go and
Paul stands up to say goodbye and we
have a hug and this we have a hug he
says into my ear
do you know Ringo I've never met him but
I'm rego come on come over here hang on
a minute he said sir Ringo sir Patrick
sir Paul hey we've got the knights of
the round table
[Applause]
[Music]